[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
está en nuestro estudio como siempre más
Romero sala Mara bienvenida buena mañana
de viernes y vamos a hablar de la comida
y el alto el alto el alza de los precios
de los alimentos que pues influye
también en como nosotros nos nutrimos no
más buenos días Raúl Así es no es un
efecto que creo que todos hemos sentido
en nuestro bolsillo en todas partes del
mundo está sucediendo en América Latina
también uno de los motivos después
definitivamente la guerra en Ucrania
también la crisis de suministros que
venimos arrastrando ya desde hace tiempo
todos está encareciendo pero es que
además la comida es una de las cosas que
más se está encareciendo nosotros
elegimos tres países de la región
latinoamericana para poner el ejemplo y
para ver la inflación interanual en los
precios de la Alimentación es decir en
los precios Cómo han subido los precios
digamos desde septiembre 2021 hasta
septiembre de 2022 vemos Que en Chile es
una lanza de 20,6% en Colombia 26,6%
México más del 14% también decir por
ejemplo en Chile algo que costaba 10
dólares ahora cuesta 12 dólares para que
nos hagamos una idea además de estas
tazas están por encima de las tasas de
inflación en general es decir que los
alimentos es una de las cosas que más se
está encareciendo respecto pues al resto
de productos Marc están encareciendo
todos los alimentos por igual no ahí
está la trampa de hecho no se están
encareciendo más los alimentos
considerados sanos Como por ejemplo los
vegetales la fruta los granos las
legumbres por ejemplo que no los
alimentos Ultra procesados y
entrevistamos a la nutricionista de
investigadora en hábitos saludables de
la Universidad de Berna magdagamba para
que nos contara qué son estos alimentos
Ultra procesados los alimentos
ultraprocesados son un tipo de alimentos
que tienen como su mismo nombre lo
indica una gran cantidad de procesos
para llegar a ser un producto finalizado
como tal Entonces en ese procesamiento
se mezclan diferentes ingredientes
algunos pueden ser originalmente
conocimientos naturales frescos y que al
mezclarse terminan siendo pues perdiendo
a veces características o propiedades
nutricionales Como por ejemplo contenido
de fibra vitaminas y minerales además
Raúl no es algo únicamente reciente hay
un estudio de Lover research institute
que muestra como a lo largo de los
últimos 30 años han ido creciendo los
precios Pero cómo han ido creciendo
distinto por ejemplo en Alimentos como
la carne la o el pollo el pescado
digamos no Ultra procesado es decir no
los salchichones no las los hot dogs no
este tipo de cosas como también han
crecido más en frutas y vegetales y como
en cambio los alimentos Ultra procesales
estamos hablando por ejemplo de los
snacks las galletas también eso la carne
congelada las pizzas ya hechas no este
tipo de alimentos para que nos hagamos
una idea o han bajado de precio o han
aumentado mucho menos esto En conclusión
Qué significa Pues que está siendo cada
vez más caro alimentarse esa no Claro
nutrirse de la mejor manera posible la
gente pues es simplemente ahora pues
muchas personas comen solamente para
sentirse saciados sino para nutrirse más
lamentable Qué consecuencias tiene para
la salud de que sea caro comer bien no
que comer mal exactamente después el
consumo de Ultra procesados cada vez
está más sólidamente vinculado en
estudios científicos con por ejemplo la
diabetes con el peor salud
cardiovascular con mayor riesgo también
de cáncer colorrectal o con una
afectación de nuestra microbiota
intestinal muy importante también para
nuestro equilibrio en el cuerpo no son
alimentos básicamente como decía
magdagamba muy poco muy poca calidad
nutricional no pero que les añaden
muchas sales muchos azúcares muchas
grasas saturadas Y eso se convierte en
un problema luego en el futuro también
para los sistemas de salud que además
recaen más sobre las personas con menos
recursos que por ejemplo tienen menos
Educación para poder tomar decisiones
sobre cómo quieren alimentarse pero
también sobre las personas que menos
tiempo tienen que duremos muchas veces
son por ejemplo las mujeres por temas de
pues tareas domésticas o las personas
con menos recursos que tienen que
trabajar más y tienen menos tiempo para
planear escuchemos
alimentarse saludablemente implica
tiempo y preparación entonces que yo
tenga los ingredientes en casa si quiero
preparar una una ensalada o algo
cocinado entonces necesito tomarme el
tiempo para prepararlo en este sentido
el trabajo no solamente desde el punto
de vista como ya lo mencioné del dinero
que ganas pero también del tiempo que te
permite después para estar en tu hogar y
cocinar porque cuando cocinamos en casa
somos más conscientes de lo que estamos
colocando en el plato en la olla en
nuestras bocas frente a este problema
mar que podemos hacer nosotros o sea lo
mismo le preguntamos a la nutricionista
también no hay investigadora desde el
lado individual algunas recomendaciones
Como por ejemplo planear mejor que vamos
a comprar evitar malgastarnos saber que
tenemos para no volver a comprar más
pero también
que la carne de hecho es uno de los
productos la carne el pescado que más se
encarecen Pues nos llega una
recomendación de comer quizás más
vegetariano escuchemos uno de los
alimentos que creo que que más sube de
precio Generalmente cuando hay la
inflación son los productos cárnicos la
carne de Herrera la carne del pollo el
pescado podemos consumir Alimentos como
la leguminosas en América Latina en
España creo también son bastante
populares por leguminosas hablo de
frijoles garbanzos lentejas cuando tú
juntas alguno de estos granos o
leguminosas con un cereal por ejemplo el
arroz tienes casi la misma calidad de la
proteína que te ofrece una porción de
carne no olvidemos Igualmente Raúl que
estas cosas que podemos hacer de forma
individual no resuelven todos sino que
es un problema social que tenemos que
resolver como sociedad y ahí algunos
apuntes por ejemplo contrarrestar estos
desequilibrios de precios abaratando los
productos que son más sanos y
encareciendo por ejemplo con impuestos
como ya sucedió en México como se aprobó
ayer también en Colombia con la reforma
tributaria los alimentos Ultra
procesados que nos aportan menos
nutrición y antes de terminar
simplemente agradecerle a Daniela
Blandón que me ayudó a entender todos
los entresijos de la información
económica de hoy todos los números y
cómo ha sido la inflación interanual esa
palabrita que tanto le gusta a ella mar
como siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda
la información nos vemos en un tiempo
aquí en directo América de Francia 24
Gracias más gracias